if you can explain to somebody exactly  the problem that they're going through  they will buy whatever you have one of  the things that's overemphasized is  product knowledge and what's under  emphasized is Prospect knowledge what we  should be focusing on is who are we  selling to more than what are we selling  because who matters more in the sale  talking about the features is going to  be irrelevant so it's more did I just  completely capture everything that  you're struggling with and they're going  to say yeah that was exactly what I'm  dealing with they're like yeah I think  we're gonna be able to help you as soon  as you say that they're going to believe  it because of how well you articulate  their problems with them more so than  how you're just going to motor mouth  about all the features of and benefits  of your thing